[Musik]
Los Angeles Californien am Strand trifft
sich die ganze Stadt die abgehängten aus
den Armenvierteln genauso wie die
Millionäre aus den Hollywood Hills
hier will ich von den Amerikanern wissen
welche Themen sie bewegen so kurz vor
den entscheidenden
[Musik]
wir haben einen Präsidenten der einfach
Geld druckt und der keinen Plan hat wenn
Sie mich fragen ist er zu alt er hätte
nie Präsident werden dürfen
Republikaner sind scheiße warum glauben
Sie das die Liste ist lang sie
interessieren sich nicht für die
Menschen sie kümmern sich nicht um die
Demokratie ihnen ist die Arbeiterklasse
in Wahrheit egal
naja offensichtlich die Wirtschaft wir
haben eine irrsinnige Inflation ich
komme aus Lais hier haben wir ein
ziemlich großes obdachlosenproblem für
Joe Biden und Donald Trump steht viel
auf dem Spiel Joe beiden droht eine lame
duck zu werden ein Präsident der keine
Gesetze mehr durchbekommt wenn die
Demokraten ihre Mehrheit verlieren und
Donald Trump muss beweisen dass die
Republikaner mit seinen Themen auf
Siegeskurs sind um sich den Weg zur
Präsidentschaftswahl zu sichern lange
Zeit sah Joe Biden wieder sichere
Verlierer aus doch kurz vor der Wahl
sind die Demokraten im Aufwind
[Musik]
das Thema das den Demokraten Aufwind
gibt ist der Streit um Abtreibungen
Amerika empört sich darf eine Frau
entscheiden ob sie ihre Schwangerschaft
abbricht dürfen Gerichte Ärzte und
Ärztinnen verurteilen die Abtreibungen
vornehmen
Fragen die Wahl entscheidend sein können
vor allem seit das höchste Gericht der
USA das Recht auf Abtreibung gekippt hat
seitdem ist in vielen Bundesstaaten
Abtreibung verboten
ich fahre nach Viktor will Kalifornien
in dem Staat sind Abtreibungen noch
legal
ich bin verabredet mit einer Frau die
das unbedingt ändern will Danielle
versüß steht regelmäßig mit ihrer
mobilen Praxis auf diesem Parkplatz der
Standort ist nicht zufällig gewählt ihre
gegenüber befindet sich eine Klinik von
plant parentoot eine Organisation die
Schwangeren Beratung und auch
Abtreibungen anbietet Frauen die hierher
kommen sollen auf Daniels lilafarbenen
Wagen aufmerksam werden
Abtreibung sollte in Amerika nicht legal
sein das ist niemals die richtige
Entscheidung für Frauen Abtreibung raubt
ein menschliches Leben und sollte in
einem freiheitsliebenden Land niemals
erlaubt sein denn es gibt keine Freiheit
für das Kind wenn das Kind getötet wird
Daniel arbeitet für eine Organisation
die strikt gegen Abtreibung ist hier
erhalten Frauen Schwangerschaftstests
Ultraschalluntersuchungen Broschüren und
Gespräche alles kostenlos was sie hier
nicht erhalten Beratungen für
Schwangerschaftsabbrüche oder
Verhütungsmittel
am Ende hat Daniel ein klares Ziel die
Frauen sollen sich gegen eine Abtreibung
entscheiden
bei der tremogam wenn eine Frau weiß
dass sie schwanger ist können wir
bereits ein Baby auf dem Bildschirm
sehen sie kann erkennen dass es ihr Kind
ist das im Mutterleib lebt und sich
bewegt wir sehen ein Herzschlag auf dem
Bildschirm ein kleines flackerndes Licht
das öffnet ihr die Augen für die
Realität und für das was eine Abtreibung
für Sie und Ihr Kind bedeuten würde
eine junge Frau kommt vorbei Anissa hat
bereits zwei Kinder und weiß nicht ob
sie noch eins erwartet Mitarbeiterin Joe
untersucht sie
okay das ist etwa die sechste Woche
also bin ich Schwangerschaft
damit hätte er NISA nicht gerechnet
wie fühlen sie sich
ich weiß nicht ich habe es einfach nur
nicht richtig begriffen ich bin davon
ausgegangen dass ich eine Fehlgeburt
habe und war schon darauf vorbereitet
jetzt werden wir nächste Woche sehen wie
es weitergeht
denken sie über Abtreibung nach nein
nein keine Abtreibung ich liebe meine
Babys ich will meine Kinder
das erste Ultraschallbild ihres dritten
Kindes für
anti-abtreibungsaktivistin Danielle ein
guter Termin doch nicht alle KlientInnen
entscheiden sich wie Anisa in
Kalifornien gibt es sogar einen
sprunghaften Anstieg der Abtreibungen
denn viele Frauen sind gezwungen aus
anderen US-Staaten hierher zu reisen in
denen Abtreibung verboten ist
das kann sehr gefährlich werden denn je
weiter fortgeschritten die
Schwangerschaft ist desto komplizierter
der Eingriff
ich finde es fair dass Frauen eine Reise
auf sich nehmen müssen um etwas zu tun
dass ein Menschenleben kostet wir
sollten es Frauen nicht leicht machen
ein Leben auszulöschen wir sollten
Frauen die Freude und die Hoffnung
zeigen die in einer schwierigen
Entscheidung stecken können der Camping
Definition ein Großteil der Amerikaner
sieht das anders und ist gegen ein
Verbot von Abtreibungen
dr prratima Gupta ist Gynäkologin sie
hilft Frauen bei der Geburt ihrer Babys
und führt auch Abtreibungen durch die
Frauenärztin erzählt mir das
Anfeindungen zu Ihrem Alltag gehören aus
Vorsicht möchte sie sich an einem
neutralen Ort treffen irgendwo in San
Diego das ist nicht die einzige
Sicherheitsvorkehrung die die zweifache
Mutter trifft
wenn ich in mein Auto steige
kontrolliere ich immer den Rücksitz das
ist einfach zu Gewohnheit geworden ich
kontrolliere den Rücksitz meines Autos
bevor ich einsteige weil ich einfach
nicht weiß ob jemand dort lauert
Ärzte und Ärztinnen wie sie sind in den
USA zum Feindbild der
anti-abtreibungsbewegung geworden werden
regelrecht verteufelt ihr haftet ja ein
mörderklischee an erzählt dr Gupta
manche sind deshalb sogar überrascht
wenn sie sie persönlich kennenlernen und
feststellen dass sie freundlich ist
helfen will
ich habe keinen Zweifel daran dass ich
das richtige für meine Patientinnen tue
ich will für Sie da sein und mich um sie
kümmern sie sind diejenigen die mit mir
im Untersuchungszimmer sitzen sie sind
diejenigen die mit mir an einigen ihrer
verletzlichsten Momente zusammen sind
und eine der schwierigsten
Entscheidungen ihres Lebens treffen
und diese schwere Entscheidung liege
allein bei dem betroffenen Frauen nicht
bei Politikern oder Richtern meint nicht
nur dr kupter die Wut vieler Frauen ist
groß seit der Entscheidung des Supreme
Court das Recht auf Abtreibung zu kippen
die Politiker und sechs Richter haben
das Leben von Millionen von Frauen in
den Vereinigten Staaten aufs Spiel
gesetzt sie nehmen Ihnen die Möglichkeit
einer sicheren legalen Abtreibung und
bringen sie in eine Lage in der sie
möglicherweise schreckliche
Entscheidungen treffen müssen und zu
einer Schwangerschaft gezwungen werden
ich frage mich wie reagieren Wähler und
WählerInnen auf die neuen Verbote die
umstrittene Scheidung des Supreme Court
durchgesetzt von erzkonservativem
Richtern die noch von Donald Trump
berufen wurden ich besuche John Pitney
der politikprofessor war jahrzehntelang
Republikaner bis Trump Präsident wurde
und er aus der Partei austrat für ihn
steht fest der Streit um Abtreibungen
könnte diese Wahl entscheiden und zwar
zugunsten der Demokraten
Berchtesgaden die meisten Amerikaner
beschäftigt das auch wenn viele beim
Thema Abtreibung gespalten sind sie
mögen die Entscheidung des Supreme cards
nicht die Entscheidung ist extrem
unpopulär Frauen sind motiviert zur Wahl
zu gehen Umfragen zeigen dass dieses
Thema die Demokraten weit mehr bewegt
als die Republikaner und das gibt dir in
Demokraten viel Unterstützung zu Lasten
der Republikaner das ist bei weitem das
wichtigste Thema
grundsätzlich immer wahlentscheidend ist
die wirtschaftliche Lage in diesem
Herbst rechts das Land unter massiver
Inflation egal ob Benzin Strom oder
Lebensmittel die Preise galoppieren eine
4-Zimmer-Wohnung kostet in Los Angeles
durchschnittlich 4.600 Dollar das Leben
wird für Millionen Menschen unbezahlbar
und viele von ihnen machen die aktuelle
Regierung unter Präsident beiden dafür
verantwortlich
es ist Labour Day eigentlich ein großer
Feiertag mit fetten Barbecues und
ausgelassenen Partys doch an den
Stränden um l.a ist die Stimmung
gedrückt
für die meisten Menschen ist das
ziemlich schwierig wir sind ja auch
nicht reich viele Menschen leiden unter
der Inflation den Benzin und
Lebensmittelpreisen sind einfach
lächerlich
wie viel mehr müssen sie momentan pro
Monat für Benzin bezahlen das sind
ungefähr 300 Dollar pro Woche pro Woche
ja aber mein Benzin reicht nur für etwa
560 km also dreieinhalb Tage das war's
ich arbeite härter ich schlafe am
Flughafen ich komme nicht immer nach
Hause man muss tun was man tun muss
Inflation ist im Moment sehr sehr hart
früher hat man im Restaurant etwa 10
Dollar für ein Essen bezahlt jetzt
zahlst du fast 18 Dollar es ist einfach
verrückt Benzin ist verrückt die Mieten
in l.a sind völlig überteuert es ist
wirklich schwer eine Wohnung zu finden
in der man längerfristig bleiben kann
ein Dach über den Kopf zu haben ist in
Amerika alles andere als
selbstverständlich erst recht in
Kalifornien was die Hälfte aller
Menschen die in den USA auf der Straße
leben befindet sich hier Tendenz
steigend immer weniger Menschen können
sich eine Wohnung leisten die Folge hohe
Mietschulden die nicht selten dazu
führen dass die Zwangsräumung droht so
wie bei Elizabeth die 58-Jährige treffe
ich im Süden von Los Angeles seit sechs
Jahren kommt sie nicht mit der Miete
hinterher
ich stand kurz vor der Zwangsräumung
der Vermieter sagte er würde mich wegen
der Mietrückstände von 2016 bis jetzt
rauswerfen
sie wohnt mit ihrer erwachsenen Tochter
auf 46 Quadratmetern ihre Miete ist mit
1200 Dollar für la niedrig dennoch
schuldete Sie Ihrem Vermieter bereits
mehrere tausend Dollar doch plötzlich
bekam sie einen unerwarteten Anruf der
ihr Leben veränderte
da wird man einfach so von einer fremden
Frau angerufen und soll glauben dass sie
einem helfen will das ist unfassbar
es ist sehr schwer die Leute davon zu
überzeugen dass es da draußen dass es
hier Hilfe für uns gibt ich weiß das
sehr zu schätzen und bin überwältigt von
Dankbarkeit
der Anruf kam von einer Mitarbeiterin
der obdachlosenprävention
hier in LA setzen sie auf künstliche
Intelligenz anhand aller verfügbaren
Daten wird berechnet wer akut von
Obdachlosigkeit bedroht ist diese
Personen werden gezielt kontaktiert
Dana thundervoort leitet diese Abteilung
ihr Ziel Obdachlosigkeit verhindern
indem man sie vorhersagen kann
wir wollen alles tun um zu verhindern
dass Menschen die traumatische Erfahrung
der Obdachlosigkeit erleben müssen wir
wollen verhindern dass Menschen aus den
Vierteln vertrieben werden in denen sie
aufgewachsen sind
weil die not so groß ist wuchs van der
Vaarts Team innerhalb eines Jahres von 7
auf 28 Mitarbeitende
260 Klienten können Sie jetzt betreuen
das Programm finanziert die Stadt Los
Angeles bei Elisabeth hat es die
Abwärtsspirale gestoppt ihre
Mietschulden wurden beglichen sie erhält
psychologische und finanzielle
Unterstützung
die massive Inflation macht armen
Menschen wie Elisabeth dennoch schwer zu
schaffen jeder Kauf im Supermarkt ist
eine Qual
the bigges ich glaube womit sie am
meisten zu kämpfen haben ist das alles
teurer wird aber ihr Einkommen gleich
bleibt sie müssen weniger Lebensmittel
kaufen aber damit immer noch genauso
viele Menschen ernähren
exorbitante Energiepreise führen sogar
dazu das Fremde ihren kostbaren Strom
klauen
manchmal stecken die Leute da hinten
ihre Telefone oder Verlängerungskabel in
meine Steckdose
was ist mit denen die ihr Leben lang
geschuftet haben ich bin unterwegs in
einem latinoviertel der Stadt und
verabredet mit Friseurin Juana von
Borstel
sie und ihr Mann Jessy stammen aus
Mexiko seit 43 Jahren betreiben sie in
Los Angeles einen Friseursalon
seitdem ich 14 Jahre alt war habe ich
niemals absolut niemals die Regierung um
irgendetwas gebeten ich habe mich nie
arbeitslos gemeldet niemals ich weiß
dass ich arbeiten kann auch wenn ich
vielleicht mal zwei oder drei Jobs
brauche aber ich habe mich nie
arbeitslos gemeldet bisschen Problem
die beiden kennen können Urlaub Arbeiten
365 Tage im Jahr am Monatsende bleiben
gerade einmal 2000 Dollar zum Leben
übrig
jessy ist dankbar für seinen Salon aber
an den amerikanischen Traum glaubt er
nicht mehr
der amerikanische Traum ist für uns fast
vergessen
als wir hierher kamen wollten wir ein
besseres Leben haben wir wollten hier
das erreichen was wir in unseren Ländern
in Lateinamerika nicht erreichen konnten
gleichzeitig haben wir der Wirtschaft
hier sehr geholfen und wir helfen der
Wirtschaft der Vereinigten Staaten immer
noch
wer hierherkommt hat in der Regel nicht
viel Geld auch jetzt werden sie ihre
Preise kaum erhöhen die Auswirkungen der
Inflation sind einfach zu heftig
spüren Sie die hohen Preise wenn Sie
einkaufen gehen wenn sie Benzin tanken
ja alles ist teuer geworden alles ist
jetzt teurer aber gerade deshalb können
wir die Preise nicht erhöhen denn jeder
sollte in dieser Situation helfen
durch Arbeit nach oben kommen dieses
amerikanische Versprechen wird immer
schwieriger ich spüre wie der Traum von
vielen hier auch angesichts der
steigenden Preise zerplatzt
ich Reise weiter nach Arizona für ein
anderes Thema das die USA tief spaltet
und einen Konflikt bei dem die
politische Stimmung möglicherweise kippt
Waffengewalt
denn die Zahl der Amerikaner die durch
Schusswaffen umkommen steigt seit Jahren
massiv an mehr als 20.000 Menschen
werden pro Jahr erschossen ein
furchtbares Massaker in einer
Grundschule sorgte mai weltweit für
Entsetzen ein 18-Jähriger erschoss in
der texanischen kleinstadtjuwalde 19
Kinder und zwei Lehrerinnen
[Musik]
unter Tränen war Präsident beiden einmal
mehr für strengere Waffengesetze
[Musik]
was in juwalde geschah war so brutal
dass die Eltern dna-abstriche machen
mussten um ihren neuen oder zehnjährigen
Kinder zu identifizieren
was sagen Waffenbesitzer dazu ich bin
auf einer Shooting Range und rede mit
dem Besuchern für sie gehören Waffen zu
amerikanischen Kultur
wir wollen unsere waffenrechte behalten
wir sind bereit mit Gesetzen zu arbeiten
die sinnvoll sind aber die Wahrheit ist
dass die Kriminellen sich nicht an
Gesetze halten das führt nur dazu dass
der Rest von uns vor extreme Hürden
gestellt wird
laut einer Untersuchung waren 2018 in
den USA 393 Millionen Waffen im Umlauf
mehr als das Land Einwohner hat
damit steigt auch die Wahrscheinlichkeit
dass Waffen in Konflikten eingesetzt
werden
viele hier sehen das anders
ein verantwortungsbewusster
Waffenbesitzer fuchtelt nicht mit seiner
Waffe an Orten herum an denen sie nicht
hingehört man mischt sich nicht unnötig
in Dinge ein und man übt den sicheren
Umgang mit seiner Waffe die Leute die
diese Probleme verursachen sind also
keine verantwortungsbewussten
Waffenbesitzer sie sind Kriminelle
ich fahre weiter zu einem gunclub ins
gotsdale 45 km von Phoenix entfernt
hier treffe ich timothie forschi erst
Rechtsanwalt für Waffenrecht bildet ein
Waffen aus und nimmt regelmäßig ein
schießwettbewerbenteil
vorschi ist genervt von den immer
wiederkehrenden Diskussionen um
schärfere Gesetze vor allem nach
Massakern wie in Waldi
warum verteufeln wir das Wort Schießerei
ich war letztes Wochenende bei einer
massenschießerei morgen gehe ich auch zu
einer man nennt es Wettbewerb 160 Leute
Schießen mit Waffen wir werden viel Spaß
haben und sehr vorsichtig sein das ist
eine massenschießerei
forschi hat offensichtlich Spaß am
Schießen mich beklemmt allein schon der
Anblick all dieser Waffen
welchen Sinn sieht Forscherin sich
ausgerechnet ein Sturmgewehr
anzuschaffen
warum sollte ich eins haben wenn die
bösen sie haben wollen sie dann
unbewaffnet sein sie versuchen ihre
Familie zu verteidigen ihre kleinen
Mädchen drei Männer mit
halbautomatischen Waffen und 30er
Magazinen versuchen in ihr Haus
einzudringen und sie zu töten was wäre
die richtige Waffe um ihre Familie zu
verteidigen wollen sie nicht auf
Augenhöhe mit den bösen sein
eine Frage die zeigt wie emotionalisiert
dieses Thema ist es wird mit dem
Beschützerinstinkt von Eltern
argumentiert nur mit einer Waffe kannst
du deine Liebsten beschützen
strengere Waffengesetze könnten dich
daran hindern und würden den Kriminellen
sogar in die Karten spielen
Gesetzestreue Menschen halten sich an
Gesetze die Bösen nicht mehr Gesetze
sind nicht die Lösung wir haben 85.000
Waffengesetze in den USA sie können
Kriminalität aber nicht stoppen weil die
Kriminellen sich nicht daran halten aber
das scheinen die Leute zu übersehen
Semester
und dann nimmt mich Timothy forschi mit
in die Schießhalle
er ist routiniert und geübt
bis es
weiß genau was er tut und worauf erzielt
sofort erkennen ihn Besucher ehemalige
Schüler darunter Jeffrey Nowak seit
seinem fünften Lebensjahr haben ihn
seine Eltern an der Waffe trainiert
heute ist er mit seinem Sturmgewehr und
seiner Pistole hier ich will wissen
warum er beides braucht seine Erklärung
ein schrägervergleich
wenn man zu einem netten Abendessen
ausgeht trägt man eher High Heels oder
die High Heels passen dafür am besten
aber wenn man joggen geht kriegt man
Laufschuhe das hier ist also etwas für
kleinere Entfernungen sagen wir drei bis
zehn Meter die ist etwas für eine viel
größere Entfernung
seine Leidenschaft für Wappen ist
spürbar ein Sturmgewehr zu haben für ihn
völlig normal
gehen Sie davon aus dass sie es auch
einmal einsetzen müssen
naja es ist besser es zu haben und nicht
zu brauchen als es zu brauchen und nicht
zu haben oder ich hoffe wirklich dass
ich nie auf etwas anderes schießen muss
als auf Papier aber falls doch will ich
mit der Waffe richtig umgehen können
die Diskussion um Waffengesetze ist
altbekannt dennoch beobachtet
Politikwissenschaftler pidney einen
leichten Meinungsumschwung auch bei
Republikanern
Massengewalt Schießereien in Schulen so
etwas erregt Aufmerksamkeit die
Befürworter der Waffenkontrolle bekommen
also immer mehr Rückenwind das ist ein
Thema das in der Vergangenheit eher die
Republikaner begünstigt hat heute nicht
mehr so sehr
ein Thema das die ganze Welt beschäftigt
Klimawandel ich frage mich welche Rolle
es in Amerika spielt immerhin hat Joe
Biden gerade erst ein klimaprogramm
verabschiedet und will mehrere hundert
Milliarden Dollar in den Umweltschutz
investieren
[Applaus]
immer im Herbst ist im Südwesten der USA
fire season zudem leidet das Land unter
einer historischen Dürre die Flammen
wüten heftig tausende Quadratkilometer
weit verbrennen ja für Jahr hunderte
Häuser gehen in den Flammen auf
verzweifelte Menschen versuchen zu
retten was noch zu retten ist
ich bin in klemmes falls Oregon eine der
trockensten Gegenden der USA
auch hier brennt es Anwohnerin Ronda und
ihr Mann Brian nehme ich mit wollen sich
ein Bild der Lage machen wie nah ist das
Feuer wie gefährlich
macht ihn so ein Feuer Angst
es ist schon ein bisschen
nervenaufreibend ich war heute zu Hause
als es gegen Mittag losgeht und ich sah
den Rauch und die Flugzeuge sofort
riefen mich bekannte an und schicken mir
Nachrichten und fragt ob ich wüsste dass
es bei meinem Haus brennt
das Feuer scheint durch den Wind von
ihnen weggetrieben zu werden sie fühlen
sich einigermaßen sicher aber viele
Häuser andere Familien müssen evakuiert
werden an diesem Tag sind es bereits an
die 50 Dürre und Brände sind sie hier
gewohnt aber dieses Mal ist das
besonders schlimm im Winter schneit es
weniger es regnet kaum und das
Grundwasser geht zurück die Folge kein
fließendes Wasser mehr genau das hat
ronder vor einem Jahr erlebt
ich stand unter der Dusche zuerst lief
das Wasser ganz normal und dann kam
einfach nichts mehr aus dem Wasserhahn
raus ich hatte gerade Haarspülung drin
und rief meinen Mann er brachte mir ein
Glas Wasser dass ich auf der Theke
stehen gelassen hatte das war das letzte
Glas Wasser das aus diesem Brunnen kam
ich spülte mir die Haare aus und wir
riefen die Firma für die Pumpen an
doch die bestätigt nur was ronder
bereits befürchtet der Brunnen ist leer
ausgetrocknet kein Tropfen Wasser mehr
ich fing an zu heulen wirklich weil sie
realisiert haben was passiert ist ich
wusste genau wie mühselig gerade unser
Leben geworden ist und dass es noch viel
schlimmer werden würde da sie hier auf
dem Land dann keine zentrale
Wasserversorgung angeschlossen sind ist
der Brunnen im Garten ihrer einzige
Wasserquelle das Problem betrifft nicht
nur rondas Familie sondern die ganze
Nachbarschaft was die Hälfte der Häuser
in der Umgebung sitzt plötzlich auf dem
Trockenen auch Nachbarin Misty sie hatte
als erste kein Wasser mehr
wurde total schlecht als ich begriff
dass ich mich um nichts mehr kümmern
kann ohne Wasser kann man kaum kochen
ohne Wasser kann man nicht putzen die
grundlegendsten Dinge konnten nicht mehr
erledigt werden
damit nicht genug sie haben viele Tiere
Pferde Ziegen Hunde alle brauchen Wasser
ihre Rettung in der Not
Nachbarschaftshilfe
wir haben bei Nachbarn Kanister voller
Wasser abgefüllt die wir dann mit
unserem Geländewagen zurückgefahren
haben zu Hause haben wir das Wasser
wieder an einmal geschüttet und konnten
so die Tiere versorgen
um langfristig wieder ein Wasser zu
kommen brauchen sie tiefere Brunnen ein
Viertel der Kosten müssen Sie selbst
tragen bis zu 40.000 Dollar ohne
Garantie das nicht auch diese Brunnen
trocken laufen als Übergangslösung
startet die Gemeinde die Haushalte mit
Wassertanks aus eine vierköpfige Familie
erhält zwei Tanks 1900 Liter einmal in
der Woche werden sie aufgefüllt das ist
der Job von Joel Herbst der 31-Jährige
ist zum beliebtesten Mann der Region
geworden er hat seinen alten Job
aufgegeben um den Menschen in seiner
Heimat zu helfen
es ist sehr wichtig für mich die
Gemeinde mit Wasser zu beliefern und
dafür zu sorgen dass sie das benötigte
Wasser bekommen
sie verlassen sich auf mich dass ich ihn
jede Woche Wasser bringe wenn Jody
Menschen beliefert erlebt er vor allem
Dankbarkeit aber auf Frust und Trauer so
wie bei Dennis Murphy der Farmer lebt
seit 59 Jahren hier
viele dieser Brunnen hier sind ziemlich
flach und trocken aus der da ist aber 60
Meter tief und auch ausgetrocknet
ist es nicht traurig ihr Land so zu
sehen ja es ist traurig man muss Wasser
haben für alles ansonsten kannst du
gleich einpacken und gehen
wegen der Dürre musste er die meisten
seiner Tiere verkaufen
das war alles grün überall Kühe und
jetzt jetzt habe ich noch ein paar
Pferde das war's
Dennis will trotzdem bleiben die
wenigsten würden daran denken hier
wegzuziehen auch Misty kann sich nicht
vorstellen ihre Heimat zu verlassen
hier ist nichts mehr Grün nein nein
absolut nicht
wie ist das für sie das Land so zu sehen
für mich ist das mit vielen Emotionen
verbunden ich bin auf einer Farm
aufgewachsen das hier ist nicht
produktiv es entspricht nicht in
Erwartungen die ich an mich selbst
stelle und wie ich mich um das Land
kümmern möchte saufen
doch am Ende überwiegt die Dankbarkeit
trockenes Land ist immer noch besser als
verbranntes Land ein
ich bin sehr dankbar dass ich das Land
habe und dass ich meine Pferde behalten
kann und sie nicht verkaufen musste
wissen sie es geht mir sehr nahe
besonders heute mit dem Feuer hier in
Plymouth es lässt mich ja nicht kalt
dass einige Menschen ihr zu Hause
verloren haben
ihr Land so leiden zu sehen nur schwer
auszuhalten
jahrelang hat Donald Trump den
Klimawandel verleugnet später jetzt da
immer mehr Menschen durch die folgen
unmittelbar betroffen sind eine größere
Rolle bei Wahlen
das Thema stand bei den letzten Wahlen
nicht ganz oben auf der politischen
Agenda der USA aber dieser Tag wird
kommen und er liegt nicht mehr allzu
fern der Klimawandel wird also nicht die
Zwischenwahlen 2022 entscheiden aber in
zwei oder vier Jahren wird es ein viel
wichtigeres Thema sein weil es auch ein
viel größeres Problem sein wird
die USA kurz vor den mitturms auf meiner
Reise habe ich ein weiterhin tief
zerrissenes Land erlebt die Wunden nach
der letzten Wahl die Donald Trump immer
noch nicht anerkennt sind längst noch
nicht geheilt die Herausforderungen
enorm
[Musik]
Klimawandel und der Umgang damit wird
vor allem in der Zukunft immer wichtiger
werden
Waffengewalt spaltet die USA bereits
seit langem Abtreibung aber wird bei
diesen Wahlen besonders wichtig sein ein
Thema das vor allem viele Frauen aus Wut
an die Urnen treibt ob das allerdings
den Frust vieler Wähler über die
Inflationen die hohen Preise überdeckt
darauf können die Demokraten nur hoffen
ihre Mehrheit ist in Gefahr für Joe
Biden steht viel auf dem Spiel
[Musik]